one o'clock meeting who are we meeting
with don't worry about it oh no please
no it's important to meet with the park
rangers they are the first line of
defense
leslie knope
hey girl what's up pencil pushers
haverford good to see you man
is it hot in here i feel hot are you
guys hot how you guys doing i'm good you
guys got any snacks
carl is the head of all outdoor security
why was he transferred from his indoor
desk job you ask listen
hey leslie have you seen avatar i never
saw avatar i wanted to read the book
first but then i realized there's no
book version of avatar what'd you guys
do for saint patty's day i was wearing
this t-shirt that said kiss me i'm irish
but no one would kiss me so
you're too important for me until one of
your own gets attacked i just feel like
there's more we can do to keep the park
safe oh you think you know how to do my
job
well you might not be so confident once
you've walked a mile on my size sevens
kind of small feet
actually seven is a worldwide average
boom
you guys ready
oh boy yeah okay we're ready
i'm gonna show you guys all the problems
we've been facing let me show you we've
been doing everything we can i'm looking
forward to working together carl after
that i'm gonna show you this log i found
it's got like 50 worms on it
i call it worm log
yeah i've always been a bit of an
outdoorsman uh when i was a kid my
parents used to make me hang out in the
backyard a lot and just run around till
i got tired but if there's any criminals
out there watching i never get tired
and ladies too
this thing is a mess we used to have
three carts actually the first one got
pushed into the creek by some kids the
second one raccoons got on too there was
urine everywhere and the third one was
recently stolen what's this one this is
the second one the raccoon piss one
all right so we're gonna just head out
oh no
you know what i think we got too much
weight
oh
that's tom probably are you serious
tom can you get off please just run
alongside the cart okay
okay here we go
whoa
so let me tell you a little bit about
the park
uh up here on the left is uh one of our
most beautiful grass fields
uh it's primarily grass
but i'm gonna make a hard left here
stick with us tom
any of this looking familiar uh yeah it
happened right over there oh yeah
i'm not surprised
take a look at this path with budget
cuts we can't afford a single safety
line there's been 10 assaults already
this year wow really can't you station a
park ranger out here we have who do you
think they're assaulting
i'm sorry i didn't mean to yell
one way or another i'm gonna get money
so you can protect jerry and all the
other
helpless pathetic people in this town
oh
you guys gotta slow down
got to take a rest for a minute no tom
sorry no can't do sun's going down it's
real dangerous out here let's roll carl
okay going fast
you